[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships Jade washaw Ramsey p ality
is my co-host today as we answer your
questions about your life and your money
open phones at
5225 Barbara starts this hour in
Charlotte North Carolina hi Barbara how
are you I am well good how can we
help I need some advice on how to move
forward with the collections company I
had a roof put on and I got several
estimates done and I got down to making
a decision between two different
ones and the insurance company kind of
stone walled on one because they came in
like $122,000 more than the other
company so the insurance company told me
that well why would I pay that much more
to have it r a rough put on when I have
a rable company here that will do it so
when I told I called this company a that
I was going with someone else he became
very angry and
beligerent and sent me an invoice for
$697 for the services he had provided
although even if you go to his website
it says that he gives free
estimates so he sent it to
collections and they keep calling me
about it I just need to know how to move
forward with that now there is one
caveat here one time when we were dis
after the insurance company Stonewall on
him he he asked me to sign this docu
sign and he told me by word of mouth I
don't have any written evidence of it
that this does not obligate you to
anything it just allows me to continue
to try and negotiate with the company
insurance company and he said I do this
all the time I know I can get them to
meet my price so I signed it you know
which was not a wise thing to do but it
pretty much said that that um the
agreement was between the homeowner and
him where his company and that in
exchange for his Services provided that
I would agree to into enter into a
formal building contract with
them and that does it say anything about
a fee for the
estimate it does what does it say well
no not for the estimate but he does say
that if I fail to enter into a form a
building contract within 30 days of
agreement to the with the insurance
company
that uh there would be a cancellation
fee for expenses incurred during the
claim scope of the scope of the claim
okay well you have two options that's
what I sign you have two options okay
option number one I was stupid for
signing something it cost me
$695 cuz you're probably going to you're
probably going to lose this cuz you were
stupid for signing that I've done stupid
too so you and me are on the same team
okay I'm not picking on you but I mean
you said you shouldn't have signed that
I'm saying you shouldn't have signed
that I think it cost you $695 when you
sign that without reading it without
half butt thinking about it so that's
one way you can just pay him the money
and call it a day and say well this
guy's a dadgum Shyer and I'm wasn't real
smart when I signed this it cost me a
stupid tax of
$695 or you can call an attorney and
take this document to them and uh pay
the attorney $250 or $500 to scare the
pants off this guy and threaten to
countersue him for his Shyer activities
and um if they don't pull the claim back
you can go either way neither one would
be really wrong morally or ethically um
a and um but but you know you the
attorney might tell you if he if he do
all I'm doing with the attorney there is
what's known as is a bluff mhm because
you're not going to sue somebody over
$695 he's not going to sue you over $695
but you're not going to get this stupid
thing off your collections until you get
rid of it and get it off your
collections either by him removing it or
you paying it so um a guy like this
though this is not his first time doing
this no no he he's a butt no question
about it um and you know what I would do
is jump on and write some reviews onl
you know you could also call him and say
I'm going to write reviews about your
company everywhere about what a crook
you are and then I'm going to pay the
$6.95 but I'm going to cost you tens of
thousands of dollars but because you're
my new hobby yeah I mean you can do that
that might be fun um because that that's
really what's going on but I mean he but
but you know I I've done stuff like this
you don't have to look at something you
agree to it and uh stinking doc you sign
there you go you know um man so I I
don't know I'm not an attorney I'm
guessing though that you probably on a
technicality that technicality being you
signed this you probably lost that money
but you could you know you can run the
guy up a rail how much how much trouble
you want to put into 700 bucks it's up
to you it's an energy question I you
want to know what though Dave I probably
wouldn't go to the attorney only because
I bet this guy's done this so many times
he would know that that's a bluff maybe
and she might end up spending
occasionally you run into somebody like
me and it's not a
bluff so I don't I would not want to run
into Dave on the other end bur it to
ground just to prove the point cuz
occasionally I just get redneck about
about it you know but uh uh but yeah I
mean but you know honestly you could
cost him a lot more than 695 the uh you
know social media and you know Yelp
reviews and anything else you can do
jump you know all around his website for
$695 I can hire a web guy to just
absolutely make a hobby out of him come
on now that's what I'm talking about
it's uh if I'm GNA if I'm going to if
I'm going to pay the guy it's going to
cost him yeah yeah I'm I'm going to have
a little fun with it after all but but
also note to self you know when I do
something stupid and it cost me money I
call that stupid Text and uh Barbara
Dave Ramsey's paid a lot of stupid tax
that's why I'm qualified to do this show
because I've done a lot of stupid butt
stuff hopefully I can keep y'all from
doing it and signing stuff you don't
have to look at that's in the category
I'm I've done it too though I've done it
too it burns you because it's some
little minor thing like that you don't
think anything about it yeah absolutely
no and the thing is when it's vague like
that when it says you may be on the hook
for you know cancell fees or what and
there's no actual dollar amount so why
am I having sign this to get you do an
estimate on a freaking roof it's not
like rocket surgery here I mean come on
yeah H yeah that's that's the thing
though I mean we've all done it and yeah
uh you you said it earlier and that's a
good phrase how much energy do you
really want to put into something like
this and um I just have to pick
occasionally I pick one burn it to the
ground and the rest of them I just Dr a
check and forget it and go on and just
decide which one you want to burn to the
ground yeah um if you're angry enough
about it Burn It To The Ground I mean
make a big deal out of it you know what
I'm going to do it cost him 60 or 80
grand I I I need to start having those
guys sign my document cuz I had an
estimation the other night the guy was
supposed to come out never came I'm like
I it's interesting how the this story
flips well and you know they say stuff
like well it's our policy and I always
go you know it's strange I've got a
policy too my policy and my policy is I
don't sign crap like this or my policy
is if if you waste my time you owe me
like can we flip it on the other side
for once yeah talk to a guy sat in the
doctor's office 2 hours wait pass his
appointment time waiting on the doctor
so he sent the doctor a bill that's what
I'm talking about yeah there you go
that's what I'm talking about hey you
going to make use up my time I mean okay
my time's valuable arrogant twerp you
know I'm sitting here trying to give you
too much money good gosh you know I mean
that's the deal you just got to decide
how you want to play this this is the
ramsy
shot
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but some something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100%
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free Cy blinds.com is the number
one online retailer of custom window
coverings visit blinds.com to get up to
40% off that's blinds.com rules and
restrictions May
apply
[Music]
n Jade washaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host today Graham is with us in
Knoxville hey Graham how are you I'm
doing well Dave how are you better than
I deserve what's
up uh me and my fiance are getting
married next June and we've been
bouncing around the idea of buying a
home versus renting and I wanted to get
your thoughts on on that
um yeah okay uh I would not buy until
you're married for sure is that what
you're talking about okay yeah we're we
were thinking you know right around when
we're getting married next um June yeah
do you guys have any will you have debt
together we will have very little debt
she has a student loan for about
$77,000 we've saved up a pretty good bit
going into our marriage and plan on
combining our finances and following you
know a lot of your instruction on that
so you pay off the debt you'd have an
emergency fund plus you'd have a down
payment
yes okay then according according to the
baby steps and what we teach you would
be in a position to buy a home let me
let me tell you an idea to think about
okay and it's not it's not a hard and
fast um I wouldn't I wouldn't call you
stupid if you didn't do it or something
like that but here's an idea to think
about I think because I'm old and I've
seen a lot that one year after you're
married you will pick a different house
than one month after you're
married because I think you will learn a
lot about each other during that year
and I always joke and say it takes about
a year of marriage to know how close to
your mother-in-law to
buy but that's the kind you know you get
to know each other I would rather
relationally you spend the first year of
your marriage all of your energy on your
relationship not on hanging
curtains and picking wallpaper mhm and
for God's sakes doing a
renovation okay so I mean I I just I
love the idea of the house not being the
purchase the move not being an emotional
relational drain instead you all just
get really comfortable with each other
and pile up a big old stack of cash and
the following Spring by a house I like
that um and it it comes from the old Old
Testament biblical story
uh in 2 Samuel that the Young Warriors
in Israel in those days were not allowed
to go to battle in the first year of
marriage they had to stay home and take
care of the family they were not allowed
to go to battle until they've been
married at least a year and so that you
know it's a bit symbolic or metaphorical
if you will uh and and it's not
something that you would be completely
unwise and stupid and foolish and all
that no it's none of that I just I just
think you're going to make a different
decision a year later I absolutely agree
with that and you've known each other
you get to know each other a little bit
better by then we've been dating six
years yeah you hav been living together
it's different I mean you're not been
married together you might have been
living together I don't know what you're
doing but but it's different yeah I I
it's it's it's a different deal man and
um and it's not it's not that dramatic
really but it's just it's subtle it's um
and and the thing I also the the thing
that that makes you do is it makes you
push back against the whole culture sure
that's yelling at you buy a house buy a
house buy a house oh renting is throwing
your money away buy a house buy a house
buy a house oh renters are going to hell
buy a house buy a house you know people
are just go crazy they're like a beagle
chasing a rabbit man and it's just you
know it's okay to have a little bit of
patience home ownership is a great plan
owning a home and getting it paid off is
a great financial wealth building plan
but everybody doesn't have to buy a
house right now just calm your butt down
you know it's like
uh and the longer you wait the more
you'll have more money to put down on it
yeah so there's that and who knows what
the interest rates will do during that
time might be fun it might oh that's
true or are you trying to make a call
here Dave are you are you calling
something okay just check I'm just
saying it be we'll be after an election
at that point and we'll see what's
happening I didn't know if you were
seeing your Shadow or
what that happens around here a lot cuz
uh yeah see things you get old things
Circle back back around if you keep the
suit coat long enough it comes back in
style you know so all right here we go
uh JT is in Santa Fe New Mexico hi JT
how are you D Jade how's it going better
than we deserve what's
up so I'm about to be at a point where
I'm completely out of Deb I've been
working on the last few years and about
to hit zero he way to
go my question is is it
a is it foolish to go back into that yes
start a business yes you just called the
ramsy show JT I
know you walked into the bear cave and
as the bear if it was
hungry you already know the answer JT
advice what's the
business uh my trade or work as a I'm a
401k consultant I do a risk of
compliance and and I don't know it's
going to start my own firm and it's a
lot to try to just bank roll why and why
what do you got to bank roll that's what
I'm
wondering well ought to cash flow you
day
one well I mean everything from you know
software agreements all sorts of stuff
wait a minute for what you don't even
you got to have customers
first well I mean I not so much worried
about that part of getting everything
started yeah but you're going fast what
are you getting
started what do you mean what I mean you
don't have any
money well I mean not enough to get this
thing going well what do you think it
takes to get this going why why have you
decid what you're describing to me you
need a computer and some sweat okay and
a customer yeah or
six well that's the thing you
know for what I'm doing I'd be go I'd be
whale hunting in a canoe and I need some
stuff to be able to do such things okay
you are not ready to open a business and
leave your job when you have absolutely
no customers whale hunting in a canoe
means that you don't have a clue where
your customers are coming from you're
not ready to open a business it has
nothing to do with a loan you need some
customers on the hook well the first
thing I do I would take my current job
and ask that they uh 1099 me and I would
contract all the work that I'm doing
right now and then go look for my own
bigger client so I have an idea for Cas
flow okay so now we're eating now why
are we whale hunting in a
canoe well we got to go after big fish
to eat big right well uh no I mean
rabbits are more plentiful let's kill
some of those and neat I think you're
missing the beauty of the type of
business that you're starting which is
this is a business you can start with
little to no overhead and little to no
cash yeah you need enough to eat on but
I don't want you floating in a canoe
looking for a whale starving to death
yeah cuz you didn't have any plan or any
background but if you got a plan for
cash flow day one on the 1099 side then
um and you think they'll do that what's
the probability of them doing
that I think so because I'd be taking on
a lot of my uh you know I'd get my own
insurance and stuff like
that okay you know this is so vague and
you have not proformed this out the
business you're in demands that you do a
better job of Performing than you have
done so far this is a vague gen a group
of vague generalities and I'm going to
go borrow money no you don't need to
borrow money you need to organically
cash flow this little service oriented
business and you're going to be just
fine uh and you need to put together a
business plan and process that has the
probability of you being able to eat and
cover the cost of basic software
services but there's no big 500,000 or
$50,000 or $20,000 outlay for you to
come out of the ground being a
consultant yeah that's I think Dave
people think if you build it they'll
come and I I think it's the opposite
you've got to go get them and then build
it while like you've got to build it
while they're coming if you build it
they will come and the movie world is
called the Field of Dreams the business
world is called a field of
nightmares so no yeah you don't you
don't want to do that you need to have
you need to have the some you know I
tell our guys all the time hey elephant
hunting is great but they're a lot more
rare than rabbits you eat really good on
rabbits there's lots of rabbits go get
the rabbits and occasionally stumble
into an elephant then that's extra but
let let's go get the rabbit let's get a
business model that turns cash here
stack some cash you're fine JT do not
borrow into the vagueness that you are
describing us you're really going to
make a mess this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
[Applause]
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership based nonprofit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all 50 states so see if
chm could be right for your family check
out more today at chministries.org
[Music]
budget
[Applause]
[Music]
Jade washaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones here at 8825
5225 in the lobby of Ramsey Solutions on
the debt free stage Aaron and Melissa
are with us hey guys how are you good
good we're good where do you guys live
just north of Rochester New New
Hampshire oh it's a bit of a halt in
Nashville it is yeah well welcome good
to have you and all the way here to do a
debt free scream how much have you paid
off $1
162,163
to
119,000 cool and uh what do you guys do
for a
living I am a service tech at a fuel
company mhm and I've been a
homeschooling stay-at-home mom for 22
years but I also do eBay sales that
works okay and how long did it take you
to pay off the 162 4 and A2 years all
right very good excellent okay what kind
of debt was it about 2,000 was credit
card 18,000 was a vehicle loan and the
rest was the house you paid off your
house look at the weird people way to go
weirdos I love it wow what's the house
worth about 500,000 very cool how much
in your retirement accounts about 250
all right bumping up getting ready to be
a millionaire look at you guys I love it
congratulations thank you how long have
yall been married 28 years all right and
five years ago somebody said something
and you changed well how'd you get
connected to us what happened Aaron
actually heard you on your radio show
and then he started listening a little
more intently and it got him thinking I
had recently picked up a full-time
babysitting job and the money just
wasn't there like we have more money
coming in where is it mhm so he brought
it to my attention and I listened and we
both just said let's do it let's go oh
wow just off the radio show yep wow and
we went out and got Total Money Makeover
and we just hit the road just like that
and four and a half years later your
house was paid off M yeah after 25 years
of marri or 20 years of marriage you did
something completely different
absolutely Wow way to go you guys thank
you got to feel pretty cool man feels
awesome you knocked it out we did I mean
how does it feel to be debt free no
payments no house payment no nothing it
feels amazing and free I bet yes yes so
you listen to the radio and you hear a
guy talking about getting out of debt
how to build wealth what did the people
around you think when you said I'm
following the radio guy we're doing
everything like like he says and that's
how we're getting out of this did people
think you were
crazy a little bit they they were
excited for us but nobody was like oh
I'm going to try that like it just
wasn't realistic I guess yeah now it is
yeah now it is cuz now it's done mic
drop boom so we were sailing pretty good
and uh yeah and then in January of this
year Aaron was diagnosed with neckan I
mean uh tongue and neck cancer oh wow oh
wow so that halted everything for a bit
yeah um the surgeon said to expect to be
out of work for four to 6
months he had just changed companies for
the first time in 21 years years and so
we weren't going to get short-term
disability oh he hadn't been there long
enough so that would mean zero income to
shy yeah it two more weeks if they could
have pushed the surgery out we could
have gotten something um but so how did
you make it through that time we had
followed the principles and we had that
3 to six month savings and we knew right
away we were going to have financial
piece that we didn't have to stress
about that right we also had a lot of
generosity from friends and family
wow so how are you doing now the piece
we had
from the emergency fund and the life
insurance was everything to me and
that's why we're here today to thank you
Dave well thank you for everything thank
you I'm proud of you and so you got a
full recovery we just found out he's
cancer free yes somebody hey that's
better than debt free I'm just saying
that free is good cancer free is awesome
yeah yeah way to go man what a great
what a horrible thing to go through but
what a great result mhm but having that
money in the account was everything cuz
we would have been thinking about that
instead of fighting cancer fighting yeah
f it takes everything you got to fight
one thing and you can't have six
different things going on yeah
absolutely yeah and you didn't have to
worry about that wow wow that's amazing
M well I'm so glad you're okay that's
the big thing me too and if you guys are
looking through your radio at home you
can't see their I drank the Kool-Aid
t-shirts so there you go they have
officially joined the cult so
um say what I just said amen I what you
I thought you said and then I'm just
okay way to go guys congratulations what
do you tell people the key to getting
out of debt is all right a big part of
it is just to have contentment with what
you have MH we've always lived a very
Thrifty lifestyle we've never carried
much debt we're content with what we
have but I think that's a huge part of
it mhm enabled you to just click that
about two notches and knock the whole
thing out right yeah it wasn't like this
massive change but you just had to get
real intentional yes you know that's a
big thing content contentment is
everything I have a key too when I uh
got diagnosed uh I came up with saying
it was
opportunities um sorry um challenges are
just opportunities to prove how strong
you are and I think that's true with
that also yeah the challenge makes you
go higher at least for my personality
you're exactly right that's exactly
right that's how things work so very
well done you guys man you're Heroes
that's amazing story I'm so proud of you
wow uh who was cheering you on outside
the two of you on the dead anybody they
were just looking at you going you kind
of lost it maybe we were definitely our
biggest cheerleaders and pushing each
other along um but our kids have also
adopted your principles and they've been
very excited watching us through this
journey so that's been encouraging to us
to see them feeding off of it they do
think we're crazy they do they live the
principles now even though one of them
is an adult well they saw it work for
you and they saw it change your life so
very cool well we got the live and give
box for you that's the baby steps
millionaires box you're almost our book
you're almost there and uh the The Total
Money Makeover book to give away and
hopefully get somebody else moving it
helped you get you moving and that book
has helped a lot of people get moving
and of course Financial Peace University
membership as well so congratulations
Heroes very very well done took control
of your life so Aaron and Melissa
Rochester New Hampshire 162,000 paid off
4 and a half years making 83 to 119
almost baby step millionaires with a
paid off house and everything count it
down let's hear a debt free Scream 3 2 1
we're Dee
yeah
yes love it wow just by listening to the
show Dave you
know life is going to come at you
sometimes life is named car wreck
sometimes it's named job layoff
sometimes it's named throat cancer but
life is going to come at you and if you
have that emergency fund in place and
you don't have any debt it puts you I
mean I mean what Aaron is saying there
it puts you in a completely different
posture to fight against whatever life
is wanting to deal you yeah that's right
cuz it's going to deal you something you
know we always tell people you need an
emergency fund it's going to rain Dave
you need to be positive I'm positive
it's going to rain yeah that's just life
it's not being negative it's just
knowing that something's going to come
your way you don't get out of life
without something way it's wisdom I mean
the flying monkeys on The Wizard of Oz
there's always going to be flying
monkeys
somewhere even if you're on the yellow
brick road there's flying monkeys you
just life is going to something's going
to come I'd love to say I know what
you're talking about but I've never seen
The Wizard of Oz you're kidding me mic
drop you're kid how you're are you an
American
I how do you how do you not have seen
the wizard it's always just seemed like
a weird movie to me so I never watched
it wow sorry you have you I'm going to
have to talk to Sam we're going to have
to remedy this
we're having a we're having a watch
party and I'm going to go rent the thing
we're going to oh my goodness boy we're
going to put it on the big screen out
here up in the event center we're going
let's have it at the Event Center have
all the people bring their children and
get the I mean the original The Real
Wizard of Oz I'm talking about the real
one oh my I believe your analogy made
sense on for some for some people
Jade I mean that's it's not just a
boomer thing I mean that's that's just a
that's America and apple pie and
Chevrolet and The Wizard of Oz I mean
come on it's a little known fact wow how
do you not know about the flying monkeys
I'm so and oh this is the Ramy
[Music]
show hey if you're in over your head
with student loans and tired of getting
calls from collection agencies if
private student loan debt is taking away
your financial piece and you don't see
any way out you need why refi they're
not a debt settlement company and
they're not connected to a bank why refi
refinances defaulted private student
loans that other places won't touch and
gives you a custom loan built for you
based on your ability to pay so when you
refinance your private student loan debt
with Y refi you'll have a payment you
can afford with a low fixed interest
rate you couldn't get anywhere else to
help you stick to your budget and work
the debt snowball and you can save
thousands of dollars to learn more about
this custom refinancing option and a
lumps some payoff option you could
qualify for after 24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to Y refi ./
[Music]
[Applause]
Ramsey
thanks for joining us America we're so
glad you're with us open phones atle
5225 Forbes reporting Americans are
overdue with their car payments at the
highest rate in nearly 30 years higher
car prices and Rising interest rates are
hindering car owners ability to afford
their vehicle payments as 6.1% of
subprime a Auto borrowers are at least
60 days past due on their loans the
highest percentage in data backing all
dating back all the way to
1994 ACC according to Bloomberg gen Z
and Millennials May account for a
significant amount of the borrowers
behind on their auto loans as the two
generations recorded auto loan
delinquency rates last year that were
significantly higher than prepandemic
levels according to NBC News interest
rates for used cars are 13 and half on
average for those with Fair Credit but
can rock it up to 21 with those with
worst credit and subprime loans
6.1% behind on a subprime loan yeah they
shouldn't have buy been buying these
cars to begin with that's the problem
yeah it's that's the problem when it's
subprime it's
because you got low credit you've got
low income there's a reason that they
don't want you borrowing money and so
they say well we'll just jack up the
interest rate right so that we cover
you're a highrisk borrower yep so
they're going to charge you super high
interest rates and and continue your
problems for you because they know but I
was forced to buy a car no you weren't
they did not have a gun you were not
forced to do anything I have chosen to
do some stupid things in my life but I
have to take ownership of the fact that
I chose to do it I was not forced to do
it I wanted it I had car fever I loved
the smell of the leather
MH and I paid way too much and I put it
on a high interest rate cuz I was stupid
yeah and um I suspect that some people
have done that well what's interesting
is it's this is significantly higher
than pre-pandemic
levels which to me indicates that after
their pandemic people got used to extra
money coming in whether it was subsidies
from the government or whether it was I
wasn't paying my student loan and let's
just go get a car let's get a new let's
get a new Camry and we have the illusion
of margin in our budget because of these
Biden bucks that's right and uh there's
not a real margin in my budget but I
will go and act like there is and
because the famous famous words of right
before you die we can afford the
payments these are the famous words of
fools right before you prove you're a
fool right because all you all you care
about is how much per month
rich people ask how much poor people ask
how much down how much a month yeah yeah
yeah yeah and they're not talking about
what these payments are cuz we know what
the average payment
is $717 last time I
checked yeah yeah so um
$600 650 the interesting thing though
the way Forbes and the uh Financial
media couches these things it says if
the
people that did this are victims right
you know it's like um the Gen Z and
Millennial Millennials May account for a
significant amount of the borrowers
behind on their loans these two
generations have recorded autol loan
delinquency rates last year that were
significantly higher than pre-pandemic
levels no I I I can't get behind that
Dave because they went to the dealership
and they said sign me up sign I'll sign
on the dotted line they they made that
choice no one said you had to get a car
loan no one said you had to spend $25
,000 on a brand new car you chose to do
that higher vehicle prices are at fault
higher borrowing cost costs are at fault
according to the article no um let me
help you you don't want to know what
causes vehicle prices to come down lower
demand uh people aren't buying them
they'll price adjust just what's
happening in higher education right now
colleges are getting ready to experience
this MH uh people have decided it's I'm
not going to pay $250,000 for degree
left-handed puppetry it doesn't make
sense mhm and end up being a barista no
I don't I'm not going to do that and um
people are waking up and you know what
if car prices are so high then don't buy
them that that's what I'm saying oh
shocking look when see here's the thing
it's that it's the ancient word we have
forgotten the ancient word no yeah press
your tongue towards the roof of your
mouth release and blow air P it sounds
like this
no no you can't tell anyone no because
immediately you're that's hate speech
now yeah no and you told me I can't do
something I just did that's right no
yeah I don't like Dave Ramsey I didn't
you know I wasn't running a poll I'm
just here to help you but Dave I have to
live in my truth and my truth is telling
me that I need self-care and I need a
new car and the way for me to take care
of myself is to get this new car work
hard own truth and I have my own truth
and they're in Conflict one of them is
not the
truth H so it's kind you're not allowed
to like own your own truth it's sorry
it's not like a thing you can buy you
can't go to Walmart and buy a box of
Truth and it's different than you know
it's a variety I get a variety pack a
different kind of Truth depending on
what truth I want now one truth if it's
in conflict with another Truth by
definition one of them is not the truth
the truth is independent of your little
feelings darling I'm I'm offended Dave I
know I'm offended
and I'm supposed to
care I love it oh it's so fun hey guys
if you can't tell we're making fun of
you yes we are definitely um yeah you're
if you make all of your adult decisions
with your feelings you are by definition
a child MH and so when you purchase
something that you can't afford with
money that you don't have to impress
people you don't even really like at 21%
on subprime and then you get delinquent
on the payment yeah
$1,142 car payment M then you become a
statistic and then people like Forbes
make fun of your entire generation
because of that and by the way the genz
and the Millennials are actually to very
good Financial Generations they've done
a very good job by and large but a
portion of every generation is stupid
well the problem is and a portion of the
Gen Z and a portion of the Millennials a
portion of the boomers are stupid the
problem is Dave is if you're always
pointing to the the problem out there
that's the reason it's the the the
dealership it's the interest rates it's
inflation it's supply chain if you're
always pointing to something out there
for your own behavior you'll never be
able to fix it you'll never be able to
fix it and you'll never get out of debt
and you'll never stop fooling around
with cars and everybody has to take that
moment and look inward when Sam and I
were getting out of debt we had one a
Jeep car payment for 303 and a Hummer H3
for 432 a month that's so much car
payments and I I mean I thought like
this is the way you're supposed to live
life this is what you have to do and it
took me listening to the ramsy show and
listening to things and people going
that's so dumb that's so stupid and at
some point you have to look at yourself
and go could could I really be making a
stupid decision and not blame you're
never going to get past it you've got to
look there's a reason you don't have any
money and it's sitting in your
driveway it's the largest thing we all
buy that goes down in value I don't hate
cars I just hate what they do to people
that can't afford them right and um you
know when you start talking I mean if
you take $550 a month and invest it from
age 30 to age 65 you're going to have
$5.5 million in a mutual fund hope you
like the car it's a $5 million mistake
yeah that your kids are crunching up
Cheerios in the back and and your
friends are throwing up in the back oh
gross I'm just saying what kind of
friends have you got well if you got a
I'm just saying who's I haven't had
friends throw up in the back of a car
since College look God just gross Jade
I'm just saying this is what okay your
kid your kid throwing up in the back
yeah the dog I'll go with the dog okay
I'll go with that the dog got
caret oh boy but either way either way
the thing's going down in
value in your case more than mine but
wow they go down and valy you like a
rock people are driving these cars for
Uber you you know those cars are getting
tore up o nasty yeah nasty I don't even
want to think about oh yeah yeah okay so
if you can't pay cash for your
car you should not buy the car that will
help you gain wealth later to be able to
drive anything you want to drive in
other words if you'll drive like no one
else later you can drive like no one
else I did today this is the ramsy
show
[Music]
hey what's up guys it's Jade if you love
the show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to ramsy
solutions.com today to sign up for our
newsletter again that's ramseys
solutions.com to sign up for our weekly
new
[Music]
newsletter live from the headquarters of
ramsy solutions it's the ramsy show
where we help people build wealth do
work that they love and create actual
amazing relationships Jade washaw Ramsey
personality he is my co-host today open
phones at
225 Jennifer is in Columbia South
Carolina hi Jennifer how are you hello
hey what's
up yeah um well I wanted to ask you a
question um my husband and I we're
having issues just saving and staying
afloat and we're really considering
doing that Cash out refinance on our
home
um because it just seems like the only
way we'll be able to get out the r and
save and eliminate it how much debt do
you
have um I have between about 80,000 my
husband is probably like 300K but that
includes the house okay how much debt
does he have separate from the
house um I'll say
[Music]
probably 50 60 and what kind of debt is
this combined is it student loans credit
cards yeah this is loans credit card my
student
Lo um and that's really the gist of it
and just how
cars I'm sorry how much is
cars um his we have one car and it's
40,000 okay one you have one paid for
car or I'm sorry one car with a car not
or do you have two cars and you have a
paid for car sitting there as well
just one car with a car note okay um
what's your household
income um well my husband makes between
200k a year um and I make 21 and then he
also had we both have
disability you make $21,000 and he makes
$200,000 yes and you said you both have
disability explain
that um cuz we both were veterans so we
do have a dis disability income and how
much is that in addition to um it's it's
probably a extra 20K um on to our income
but it's just like can I can I be honest
with you y'all make far too much money
to be this
broke yeah you make 200 you have
$221,000 coming in year $50,000 coming
in yeah 200 yeah two even more that's
quar of a million dollars a
year y you're spending like you're in
Congress and you have $130,000 of debt
here's here's what I'm telling you and I
want you to really understand this if
you just Liv lived on half of what you
make which is still more than the
average family in America almost double
the average family you would be out of
debt and it wouldn't take you borrowing
on your mortgage to do it or refinancing
or cash Ting your morgage to do
borrowing on the mortgage is absolutely
the most horrible ridiculous thing you
can do because it will enable you to
consider this chaotic out of control
disorganized overspending life and
you're going to gra crash this
car girl I I mean you guys got to know
you got to get control you know that
don't
you yeah yeah so the house uh what's
your what's your mortgage payment what
are you paying on this
house um well it went up to $1900 it was
,100 um all right so that's not your
problem it's just your living I I I
already know the answer to this but
you're not on a budget
correct I I mean I feel like we are we
don't do anything yeah but that's not
the
same okay
$250,000 is going somewhere aren't you
kind of curious where it went I am I I
am yeah yeah I think it's kind of like
whoa this is a mystery so um what does
your husband do for a living he's a
truck driver and that that's where I
wanted to get into he's a truck driver
and he'll go to work and it'll be times
where um because the fuel prices are so
high everything he comes out of pocket
he's on the $10.99 but he works with the
company and um you don't make wait a
minute he does not make $200,000 a year
yeah he grosses $200,000 a year but his
net income after expenses he's an owner
operator
right yes there's the problem he's not
netting
200,000 okay he's running a business
that brings in 200,000 and then he has
repairs and Fuel and other things out of
that am I
correct yes okay so you do not have an
income of 200,000 your income is the net
profit on on his business after expenses
are paid which is more like 100,000 that
sounds right okay uh does that sound
right to you yeah that probably sounds
better yeah okay so Jennifer what do you
do what's your job well I just finished
I just finish school I'm an esthetician
and I'm trying to start my business um
and you know I've been an at home mom
but now um you know but I'm also trying
to start a business but I want to
challenge
I I want to challenge you with your
esthetician work right now it sounds
like it's more like quarter time to
parttime based on your earnings am I
right well my income comes from
disability so you haven't earned 21 you
haven't earned anything from this degree
yet right I just graduated probably like
two Fridays ago oh okay well
congratulations that's great okay thank
you now here's what we're going to do
all right I'm going to we're going to
set you into Financial Peace University
it includes a budget buting Gap called
every dollar and then the other thing
you ought to do is you ought to contact
a ramsy coach in your area you can find
them online with us at Ramsey Solutions
and sit down with them because someone
needs to help you guys put together a
set of books for his business and now
for your business so you actually know
what profit you have after taxes are
paid and after the expenses of the
business are paid and then you will know
what it takes to attack this debt it
sounds to me like you're 40 ,000 car
probably needs to be sold yeah cuz I
think it's too much car in this
situation and my guess is you probably
have a very high interest rate on it and
the reason you have only have one car
that's super expensive is he's in a
truck all the time he's over the road
and an owner operator
so you guys need you guys need to get
your uh your your net profits figured
out so that you can get organized and
get on a budget and begin to attack pack
these debts and we're going to list them
smallest to largest and you're going to
be able to do it in that order I thought
for a few minutes there you had a
$250,000 income and that was super
absurd that you couldn't pay off
$140,000 worth of debt making that but
you don't you have probably a $100,000
$120,000 income give or take and uh
that's still enough to get you out of
debt but it's not it doesn't make you
look as uh out of control as I initially
thought you were okay you you know all
it means is you're you're right your
budget is probably not super got all
kind you know you're probably not eating
caviar every night or something here
it's not that's not what's going on but
uh but but you are going to have to
tighten up and you are going to have to
make a decision and it's probably going
to take you about 3 years of sacrifice
including selling this car and getting a
much more reasonable cheap car
temporarily to get yourself out of into
control but we'll get you started in
Financial Peace University and get you
started on the every dollar budget and
help you get moving
this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show hey folks you know that sinking
feeling when you make an offer on a
house you love and then you hear there's
another offer you need the Churchill
Mortgage home fire Edge super fast
pre-approval and a secured interest rate
plus a $5,000 seller guarantee gives
your offer the best chance of being
accepted the home buyer Edge from
Churchill gives you an advantage over
those other guys go to Churchill
mortgage.com today to learn
[Music]
more
[Applause]
Jade washaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host today our question of the day is
brought to you by neighborly your hub
for Home Services when you need repairs
for your home neighborly helps you find
local home service providers like Mr
Rutter Plumbing Mr electric and more
don't wait until something goes wrong be
prepared download the neighborly app
today yeah today's question comes from
Allan in Pennsylvania he says Hey Y'all
I've recently seen companies advertising
cashback debit cards I'm in the process
of transitioning out of using a credit
card for day-to-day purchases my
question is how does a cashback debit
card work and where's the money coming
from uh that's a really good question
Dave I hear this a lot and a lot of
people have popped in saying Jade this
is a great great way that I can build my
credit uh it's a debit card that will
report to the credit card companies or
you know report it on your credit report
but what they're not telling you is
you're still borrowing money no no the
the cash back credit card is just a like
a Rewards Card well the ones that I'm
looking at you're talking about the one
now
now Experian launched one that only
works with Experian boost and it reports
on the credit bureau right okay but this
is simply like discover has 1% back on
uh discover points or uh if you get
airline miles this is just it's a cash
back
rewards I don't have a problem with that
debit card um and where does the money
come from it comes from transaction fees
Merchant fees so we don't accept credit
cards on our website because we tell
people not to have them and that would
be hypocritical for me to make money off
of something I tell people not to do
okay so we take debit cards on our
website when you use your debit card on
our website we pay a merchant fee a
transaction fee most cases I ours is
different but because we doesn't do a
lot of volume but basically it's around
3% okay so 100 bucks I pay 3% to the
merchant fee to transact the debit card
okay they can then take part of that fee
and give it back to you to get you to
use the debit card more because they
make money when you use your debit card
they make transaction fees not off of
you but off of the merchant that you are
buying from same thing's true with the
credit card by the way yeah uh credit
card pays the exact same fees as a
matter of fact yeah uh Merchant fees are
exactly the same we don't pay less or
more because it's a debit card um we've
actually had to argue with a few of
these people that they wanted us to they
wanted to force us to accept credit
cards to get to process our transactions
no no no no that won't work can't do
business with you but um so a lot of a
lot of your uh um the the credit card
companies don't just make money on the
interest M on your debt they also make
money on the transaction fees absolutely
and so when they're giving you airline
miles or whatever it's not just because
they're screwing you with 18% interest
it's also because the merchant
transaction fee is doing that and so
yeah I don't have a problem with this
let me tell you what the breakdown on
this is though the the only issue it's
the wrong
question okay because you should not be
asking a question of I want to modify my
spending habits my method of payment in
order to get 1% yeah because that means
every time you spend $100 you get a
dollar this is not for this is not going
to move the needle for you well and
somewhere in your brain you're going to
think oh if I spend more I'll get more
money and it's going to make you want to
spend spend your way into wealth when
you're trading a $100 expenditure for a
dollar cash back that's you just lost 99
bucks on this okay yeah so uh I mean
this is so this is the the way that
these companies work though it's a
feedback loop and psychological feedback
loop and they're trying to keep you
spending and consuming because that's
where the transactions are where they
make all their money and so it's not
where you make all your money though and
when you're asking the question oh boy I
could get 1% back how about oh boy I'm
not going to spend a hundred bucks true
that and now I just made a hundred times
more money than even asking this
question a hundred times more money I
Like It by you know you know how you
double your money you fold it over once
put it back in your pocket right I mean
that's it that's quit so don't let these
people suck you
into trading a hundred for a dollar a
dollar for a penny don't don't make this
transaction and then walk around like
well I am very sophisticated I have a
cash back who gives a crap yeah you're
not sophisticated you're trading a 100
for one the focus is wrong yeah so it's
okay if you want to get cash back it's
not bad but the fact that you're even
worried about it is bad absolutely uh uh
since I wrongfully set myself up I feel
like we should talk about the other
thing too yeah okay the other thing is
there is now a debit card that does
report on your credit bureau yeah and it
is only with the Experian bank that's
the only one and it only works if it
only reports if you do Experian boost
now what Experian boost is is a fee that
you pay to the credit bureau reporting
company called Experian you pay them a
fee and they will boost your credit
rating
however those of you that have a boosted
rating need to know that no mortgage
company will use your boosted rating to
qualify you they will use your non
boosted rating and so you used your
Experian debit card you opened a bank
account with Experian so that they could
make these fees we were just talking
about so that you could pay them extra
to boost your credit while using their
debit card all to build a boosted score
that a mortgage company won't take
there's other ones too Dave that will
yeah there are the ones that they'll
give you they'll send you a card in the
mail and they'll say we will take a
portion of your paycheck and make it a
portion of your own money and make it
available to you as credit on this card
and so you spend let's say you spend
let's say you get paid $1,000 they'll
take $300 over and they'll say spend it
on this card and so they're but they're
Froning you the money first that's a
prepaid credit card and then they'll
come in and whatever you spent for the
month they'll come in and they'll take
it out of your account yeah but that
that is actually debt yeah that's what
I'm saying yeah yeah that's actually
debt that's a prepaid credit card this
is but they call them debit cards
they're calling them that erroneously it
it is not the technical it can't a debit
card does not count on on your credit
score that's right period okay unless
you run it through Boost but the uh um
not as of right now anyway so yeah
prepaid credit cards back in the day had
huge fees on them I suspect that does I
haven't seen that product um and it was
mainly being used by um poor people yeah
lower income people it's like you know
same people shop at the pawn shop and
think they're going to get rich off a
lotto MH it's the same poor people and
that's why they're poor and it's one of
the reasons they're poor anyway yeah and
uh Dave Ramsey hates the poor no Dave
Ramsey works his whole life so that
you're not poor I spend all of my time
helping you not be poor I want you to
not do poor people's stuff and that way
you're not poor okay and poor people
stand in line the number one ZIP codes
that buy lotto tickets are poor
neighborhoods by far the vast majority
of lotto tickets purchased are in poor
neighborhoods so I'm not making that up
I mean it's an actual data point and
it's not a moral judgment it's just
going hey how's that working for you you
know it's the same neighborhood that has
tital Pawn Tote The Note lot and rent to
own washer and dryer for God's sakes
that you could buy for 50 bucks at a
garage sale but instead you pay 2,000
bucks for it rent to owning it but this
is all short-term thinking thank God
it's Friday oh God it's Monday and
that's where the prepaid credit card
shows up is in that environment it's
also so payday lenders in that
neighborhood and um what is these
commercials God they're awful cash
advance place well it's payday lenders
it's cash advance but uh just horrendous
and the interest rates with the payday
lenders
800%
800% now you want to find somebody
that's picking on poor people it's those
people that are picking on poor people
they're they're making a good living
getting rich off the backs of poor
people when you charge poor people 800%
and by the way rich people don't pay
that they don't play that and they those
those things aren't in the rich
neighborhood they're not even in middle
class
neighborhoods you know it's your lotto
tickets it's these it's a short-term
it'll kill you guys it'll kill you don't
fall for it don't fall for it don't fall
for it don't fall for it just go make
some money live on less than you make in
stack cash this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
hey folks Dr John deloney here with some
great news you get to choose whatever
you do good or bad moving forward the
choice is yours and when you're
intentional about making good choices
over time they become Healthy Habits
Like choosing to slow down and make time
for a daily practice of prayer and
meditation one thing that has helped me
with the daily practice of meditation
and prayer is hallow hallow is the
number one Prayer app in the world and
they're giving you 3 months free to get
started that's three months free to
prioritize your mental health and be
intentional about finding peace through
calming music prayers meditation and
more and hallow isn't just Catholic you
can tailor the content towards your
faith tradition if you don't have a
faith tradition this is a great place to
learn more about it from scripture
readings and prayers to journaling Hall
makes it easy to practice mindfulness
build a deeper more meaningful spiritual
life and choose peace remember palow is
giving you 90 days free imagine the
peaceful habits you can establish in 90
days go to hall.com Ramsey today and
follow the simple prompts to start your
free 90-day trial that's hall.com
Ramsey
[Music]
Jade washaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
America we're so glad you're here open
phones at
88255 225 in the lobby of ramsy
Solutions on the debt free stage Colton
is with us hey Colton how are how are
you doing most excellent thank you for
having me here today guys we're honored
to have you good to have you man where
do you live at Austin Texas oh fun
welcome to Nashville and how much debt
have you paid off Colton
62,200 um and then I ended 2022 with uh
right over 71,000 wow wow good for you
what do you do for a living uh it's
diverse job description uh do a lot but
uh we work in a pretty small company uh
but I can be tasked by any of our
marketing heads our sales heads Finance
uh rcoo calls me the control center it's
where all the information comes together
and then actions disseminate that work I
like it I like it pretty cool so you
averaged $2,000 a month in debt
reduction starting out only making
$2,000 a month so must most of this must
have happened in the back end yes it was
a journey snowballing throughout the
whole thing and as we continued down it
we definitely got to to see your income
went up you were able to slam it MH yeah
and every everyone that went down it was
the next one came up there you go I love
it good for you what kind of debt was it
um so it was all sorts of debt we uh had
student loans mostly uh private and
federal uh had a car loan bunch of
credit card had some P two uh medical
bills I had to pay and then there was
one little stupid tax I found myself in
the whole time
too okay I found myself in more than one
so that's not bad at all
what happened how did you find us what
got you started on this 31 months ago
yeah so I was actually I was on the
lower end of the income of this journey
and I found myself in a place where I
really needed a vehicle and uh I was in
a place where it was mandatory for my
job and I had to trans uh commute to get
everywhere and I was just looking at
things I was like I have no money I'm
right out of college like I I have no
means to get a car how can I do this so
I started going through you know my
diligence to do the research and find
out um and I finally found the home base
when I found Ramsey and this baby steps
and I read the the book to him Money
Makeover and I remember buying it at a
Half Price Book store and I was like $20
I bought this book and by the time I
finished the last page and I closed it I
was like that's a million dollar book
and it's going to change my life and wow
thank you okay so you're broke and you
read a $20 book and you need a car how
you getting a car what happened so the
before before I got the book I actually
got the car oh you went into de yeah I
went that was the stupid t000 you solv
that problem with
then I read the book I was like oh and
this was like two months afterwards and
I was like oh could have saved my
problem so how much how much was the
card at in the 62 uh 12 oh that's not
that's not too too bad that's good okay
yeah you're in good shape and then you
turn around and 31 months later after a
$20 book at of used bookstore boom there
you go I like it yeah I like your style
and all the strategies you know getting
the involved with the career and getting
passionate and doing everything you can
just so many facets of your life just
being able to approach them and andn win
in every single one of them very cool
what did that look like for you I mean
obviously you got your income up and you
did it doing obviously it sounds like
you're a jack of all trades but how what
did that look like how did you do it
yeah it was actually a transition from
from a few different jobs uh started on
the lower end I was operations manager
for a freight and logistics company um
and that worked really well we did a lot
of things like we did a lot of different
business like Freight was only a part of
it we were moving we were doing
International we had a lot um but then I
got a job offered um for a new company
and it was a huge step up and I was like
definitely that's a place I want to go
pursue and I talked about it with the
owner at the time and and he was like do
it um and then and then that second
company sold and that's where I find
myself in this new company and and this
is the place where I've just experienced
the biggest the most growth and and the
biggest wins all over just relationally
I got a feeling I know why yeah me too
think the secrets office is called
Colton uhhuh I see that he's the he's
the captain of his own ship well done
sir well done well played I like it okay
how old are you 30 years old 30 years
old and you paid off 62,000 in 2 and2
years 31 months and you did that
starting at
$244,000 almost no income and jammed it
all the way to 71 and did this what do
you tell people the secret to getting
out of debt is yeah I have to believe
it's Vision you know you get to the
place where you're in a place and you're
like I am done with this I don't want
this anymore and I am going to get to
the other side you find the vision you
find the purpose and then you can start
setting goals the vision starts the
goals follow the plan thank you Dave for
giving us the plan because that was the
easy part the plan proceedes and then
once you start hitting the goals and you
start doing everything it all snowballs
it all gets bigger and better and you
win so much that that you're encouraged
and you're motivated and it keeps going
and keeps going um but that all started
with the vision you get to the point
where you said I've had enough and I'm
ready to get past it yeah amen what was
your what was your vision cuz everybody
everybody getting out of debt has that
thing that they're picturing right like
that's the why like if I can just get
there what was yours actually this is
actually hits the show perfectly is like
generosity like I want to go out and I
want to tip outrageously I want to just
give I want to do so much for everyone
but if I'm in a place where I'm making
so little money and I'm paying
everything I can to the banks uh then we
find oursel in a place we don't have
very much money to give out we we can't
be generous as we want to be so my goal
is to be as generous as possible and to
get there I want to I want to take the
steps
and you figured out that you have a math
problem if you're broke to be generous
yeah you get you broke broke people it's
hard to be generous when you're broke I
mean you can be generous with a smile
you can be generous with kindness and
opening the door make somebody a pie but
uh but outrageous generosity it requires
coin yeah well done sir well done I like
it very very good good good good play on
that who was encouraging you you know so
that's the biggest thing I I I could say
about the whole journey is like not many
people understood at all like no one
really got it like my dad would say
colon you need a new bed FR my mom's
like when you going to open up that bab
that dating budget I need grandchildren
like like everyone around the dating
budget wait a second like come on how
much can I put there Jade like talk to
me through it talk me I can't help you
no uh but so so people may not
understand the steps or the intensity or
how focused you have to be to do it but
I was surrounded by people who supported
me like employer after employer you know
I I got this morning at 10:00 a.m. I was
sitting in a diner up north and uh just
out of nowhere my CEO and our director
of sales is sitting right next to me
they called me out of nowhere and said
hey guess what we're here in Nashville
we're coming down to Franklin you going
to do the debt free scream with you yeah
and I I was like this wasn't on the plan
this wasn't on the agenda but it's that
level of support that I've had the
entire Journey it's like friends family
my church everyone around me I am so
supported and the fact that we have our
CEO and our director of sales here today
is just a testim Prett awesome you're an
easy guy to support though you're an
easy guy to get get behind I I like
placing my bets on a horse that's going
to win so yeah well done well done sir
proud of you thank you sir well played
well played and uh congratulations we're
happy for you we've got a cop we've got
the uh live and give speaking of that
box for you the baby steps millionaires
book which is definitely your next stop
and The Total Money Makeover book now
you have a new one and you can give that
away or give that used one way one of
the two and then Financial Peace
University membership as well so thank
you for making the trip from Austin all
the way to Nashville and uh thanks to
your uh your leadership team for coming
in and supporting you that's real
leadership that's very well played
ladies very well played and uh good
stuff all right Colton from Austin Texas
$62,000 paid off in 31 months making 24
to
71,000 it helps to be a force of nature
count it down let's hear a debt free
Scream 3 2 1 I'm Deb
free
yeah
wow that's how it's done ladies and
gentlemen
Wow and his dating budget is open for
the ladies you think it is you think
it's ready now it's ready I'm looking at
him you think it's it's happening now
his face card is not declining so he's
he's he's
ready have you ever heard that my friend
told me that's the cool thing to say oh
is it okay I I say it again cuz I I need
just a little bit of cool over this way
this guy's face card does not decline oh
okay that's what you say when someone's
handsome okay I got it I it took me a
minute but yeah took me a lot longer
didn't take me as long as that other one
you were oh my God that one took me a
week yeah oh I'm so slow but it's good
though I'm glad I didn't say that about
him so that that would have been weird
that's right yeah you can't say thate
that be real weird that would be
weird God help us this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a 100 if you run a business
with different software systems that
don't talk to each other that's why
there's netw Suite by Oracle in the
early days of ramsy we were using
different systems for all of our
business units we needed one single
source for accurate data netw Suite was
the software we used to optimize and
take us to the next level netsuite gave
us the visibility into all of our
numbers so that we could communicate
across departments and plan ahead better
and as we grew it scaled with us net
week worked for ramsy and it will make a
difference for your business too join
the more than 34,000 customers who Trust
Suite to help make them smarter and make
better decisions and level up their
operations to learn more get a free
product tour at netsuite.com
Ramsey that's netsuite.com
[Music]
Ramsey
Jade washaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host today wow that guy was
inspiring the energy off of him amazing
Norman is in Philadelphia hi Norman
welcome to the Ramsey Show hi Dave and
Jade thanks for taking my call sure
what's up um here's my situation I'm a
70 years old a part-time
Pastor uh bational actually here in
Suburban Philadelphia small
congregation and um we are having to
unexpectedly close due to some horrific
circumstances if you want to know them
I'll tell you they're not super relevant
to my problem U or to my question but um
I had been planning on working for
another couple of years and then
retiring and then looking for
housing uh this quote retirement is
being forced on me a couple couple of
years early not through my own doing
it's just the
situation and so I'm wondering um what
is wiser for me to do to purchase or to
rent a couple of things that play of a
role in my decision my parents are still
alive in their early 90s and I'm
committed to staying in the Philadelphia
area for as long as they're alive which
means I'm in the Philadelphia expensive
housing market otherwise I could look
for much less expensive housing housing
somewhere else in the in the country so
you've been in a
parish yes I've been in the parish right
yeah so have you been saving money
towards purchasing a home yes I have I
owned a home for 43 years which I sold
about two years ago and have a maximum
of $150 to
$170,000 for a down payment from that uh
home
mhm and do you have an in what is your
income situation going to
be uh it'll be once I retire in the 70k
range okay right now it's a bit higher
than that because uh my wife and I are
still working part-time for the next
couple of years but once we actually
retire it'll it'll uh it'll drop a bit
down into the 70k
range okay so if you
purchase and your
90-year-old parents pass well when your
90-year-old parents pass we're all going
to pass so um when they pass whether it
be 2 months or 20 years I don't know um
right then your intention would be to
leave
Philadelphia probably yes mostly because
of costs okay
um well the the general rule of thumb
and it depends on the market and the
specific area within the specific Market
to get the exact math but the general
rule of thumb is if you're not going to
be in a property 2 years you're better
off to rent and so right my my thought
my thought is right now that if we
actually bought something we would
commit to staying five to seven years
okay even if let's say my parents died
in two years yeah okay uh so we would
just we would just buy something that we
would we would stay in it for at least
the five to seven years regardless of
regardless of their situation you would
be at least five yeah uh if um how is
their
health uh right now it's pretty good
actually okay all right well that's good
that's wonderful yeah yeah
um now my father-in-law's 94 and he's
sharper than I am so you know that's
that's how we want to be right um my my
dad will be 92 next month
[Applause]
yeah I would buy I would buy you got a
fiveyear horizon you'll make money on it
it'll end up being net net cheaper than
having rented over five years that's
right um I would buy okay some people
have suggested I maybe rent for a year
and wait for the interest rates to drop
because it's an election year well that
that might be so but during that year
prices might go up too because we still
have a housing shortage and even though
inventory is uh there's not a lot of
people excited about the real estate
market right now there's still more
buyers than there is Sellers and so
we're seeing prices go up ironically
while interest rates are going up uh but
there's not a lot of volume of sales
it's just uh but but we've not seen a
decline in values um not Nationwide and
I'm Philly's a good strong market so I
doubt it's experienced that so I I I
would buy you got a fiveyear horizon
we're we're going to commit to a
fiveyear minimum you'll make money in
that five years versus having rented
you'll be glad you did um and yeah
mathematically I would buy and and let's
see what else you stabilize your costs
mhm you're you're in the housing market
I am debt free I am debt free okay
that's good great what do you have I
don't I don't in a 403b like what do you
have in
retirement well uh it's it's actually
way too complex I'm going to have about
nine sources of income also including
International uh so it's a pretty
complex picture but you don't have any
cash to get a hold of in addition to the
150 to just pay cash for a house I do
yes I do yes but I would consider that
I'm not sure yeah what would you
recommend um
uh for putting down for down payment as
much as possible I like the 100% Down
plan yeah yeah yeah I really would I
mean I don't know what your net worth is
there's a lot of different things going
on in your story here but um I wouldn't
use your last dime to do it but if
you're sitting on another five or
$600,000 somewhere and you use 400 to go
with that you still got 200 plus these
nine sources income and a paid for house
that's where I would be if I'm in your
shoes I'm going to pay cash for
something um but I don't know that you
know we'd have to really dig further
down into your numbers to figure that
out so at what point let's let's talk
about that a little bit let's say you
have uh a million dollars MH out what
percentage of that would you pull out in
order to pay cash for your your primary
home the least possible to have a house
that is quote unquote reasonable and
that you know that's going to shift all
right Philadelphia Philadelphia is not
an inexpensive market right uh this is
not Dayton Ohio of course okay it's not
abene all right it's uh you know it's
going to be more expensive it's adjacent
to New York hello okay so we're in a you
a you know a very uh uh I mean and and
Philadelphia has got a wide variety of
neighborhoods but easily $400,000 yeah
yeah I'd go 400 or 500 I would not go
900 out of a million right sitting there
with $100,000 and all of it's tied up in
a house yeah absolutely but that 500,000
feels like to me too that's pretty tight
I mean yeah but somewhere around that
half million Mark and so that's why I
say if he's got another 5 or 600,000 on
top of that 150 from the old house that
he sold and he pulled out two or three
of those hundred and still had two or 3
hundred laying there and he pay cash for
450 I mean that that starts to be um
Optimum yeah and um that's a less than
median price slightly below the middle
in Philadelphia right now so that that's
where he would be and that you know but
again paying cash gives you a a lot
of ability to just sit and smile
absolutely and you don't have anything
tugging at your wallet every month there
it's a different a different environment
so very smart for pastors to uh hear
this uh not a lot of pastors
percentagewise these days have parishes
that's right not as often as they used
to parishes uh were traditionally or are
traditionally um employer furnished
housing and it often times was the house
next door to the church so they were
handy to the church and they could go
over and turn on the lights and uh he
was bivocational so as a smaller Church
likely I mean he wasn't even full-time
Pastor right uh in terms of income off
of it he probably is full-time in hours
but the uh um there's still usually the
parishes have gone away if though you
are a pastor or sometimes they have an
old Parish around a church that's gotten
started again or something and they'll
put the youth pastor or the worship
minister in there in those cases any of
you that are doing that make sure you're
still paying yourself a house payment
even though you don't have a house
payment because you're going to end up
where he is having to buy a house at
some point in your equation there's very
few of you I mean if you're
a
uh a priest in some of the uh
denominations some form of Catholicism
you might have no housing needs the rest
of your life that's possible uh but the
vast majority of you that are in a
parish are at some point going to need
to provide your own housing whether it's
at retirement at a job change or
whatever it is uh and the vast majority
of Evangelical churches these days are
not doing parishes they've not worked
out well and so be prepared is the moral
of the story and Norman has done a
really good job preparing done a really
good job there you go ladies and
gentlemen that puts this hour of the
ramsy show in the
[Music]
books Dave here you can find all of our
shows with the Ramsey Network app on
your smartphone phone it's the only
place to listen to the entire back
catalog of episodes download the Ramsey
Network app in your favorite app store
[Music]
today live from the headquarters of
ramsy solutions it's the ramsy show
where we help people build wealth do
work that they love and create actual
amazing
relationships Jade washaw Ramsey
personality is my co-host today thank
you for joining us America open phones
at
5225 sha is in Fort Lauderdale hi Shawn
welcome to the ramsy show what's going
on Dave how you doing today sir better
than I deserve what's
up um so quick question I guess um I'm
about $144,000 in school debt I
am $38,000 in car debt um I make about
$50,000 a year um I'm 10% owner of my
business with ability to stake up to 30%
um once I reach you know goals of
$250,000 um on a yearly basis um and I
have about $3500 in credit card debt um
my bills exceed about half of my U
monthly earnings what is your monthly
earnings
about pre-tax it's
$41.90 I think so you're taking you're
taking home three
grand yeah okay and my bows are about
2,700 including a $700 car payment now I
would like yeah I would immediately sell
my car um the problem is is I got into a
car accident about 4 months into having
the car MH um and the motorist who was
at fault in the accident um had
uninsured uh was an uninsured motorist
so I didn't have uninsured motorist on
my insurance either and yeah I exceeded
about I think it was $26,000 in
damage um so yeah um kind of in a rut
here um your Collision should cover it
even if they are uninsured it did it did
it did um so why your car
fixed no the car is fixed I'm I'm now
driving it again um it's it's all good
now but it took about two months to
repair and I needed to get to work at
the time what's that got to do with you
selling it you needed to get to work and
you did
what so I needed to get to work at the
time and I started renting a vehicle
while I didn't have my car while I was
getting um fixed okay but you still
right now you still have a $38,000 car
that what's the car worth today it's
fixed you're driving it what's it worth
about 29 I'd say who said Kelly blook
for private sale or trade in private
sale okay so you're nine in the hole and
how old are you I am 25 okay all
right well I had a job prior to this
where I I was spending probably a little
more than my means I was making about
$100,000 a year um and then the company
sold and major layoffs um so I I am a
business owner it's just um you know
business just
started okay all right and so what's
your question how can we best serve you
just trying to get out of this I mean my
mom's always told me I got hands that
just money flows through you know so um
just just start listening to your
podcast and I think hearing it from you
might might really help so you're brand
new to the ramsy stuff I am okay that's
cool all right well um the good news is
your hands are not a DNA issue your
hands are money flowing through is a
choice agreed right yeah it's not like
it's a curse it's just that's how you've
chosen to do it um and I don't want your
mom speaking anything negative like that
over you again tell her to quit doing
that okay no it's all I know it's all in
good fun but even joking you kind of
owned it and I want you to own I am a
responsible extremely sharp 25y old guy
that recently made 100 Grand in soon
will again um that used to make mistakes
with money and I don't make those
mistakes anymore that sounds more like
the guy I know yes sir okay uh and
because that is actually who I'm talking
to you're calling me on a radio show in
front of a whole bunch of other people
put bearing your soul um taking a great
risk in order to figure out how to fix
something that you don't know how to fix
I think that's pretty
courageous yes sir I appreciate
that so for me my two cents in this
whole thing is I you know I'm always
going back to the baby steps and I know
that right now you're making $50,000 a
year I'm always looking for a way to
increase my income if I'm you is there
something else that you can do on the
side I know you're a business owner I
know you've got a lot on your plate is
there something else you can do to bring
some more money in I was thinking about
getting a second job at maybe a bar or
something where I can you know go and
make a good amount of money I mean I
know some people in the business great
who would take me in with open arms um
it's just I don't want to exceed my
ability to be able to run the business
as an operator I don't want to impact my
day-to- day you know getting no sleep or
something in there there there is part
of this that you're going to have to
embrace that you're going to go through
a season of difficulty and that
difficulty does look like long nights
being tired working your your fingers to
the Bone like there is going to be a
season of that and I think that's part
of you just embracing it here's the
thing it's not longterm short
term right so I do think that your idea
of looking into that I would just go
ahead and move forward with that
assuming that the return on that time is
going to be worth it how much do you
think you could
make um I had one of the girls who
worked there tell me they made 700 in a
night I mean I'd probably say average
400 a Night 500 night so you can make
almost as much during that at night as
you're making during the day right now
right right right of course and so that
solves a lot of problems right there and
again it's a temporary thing this is all
to clean up the mess because if you had
zero payments right now your life would
be completely different agreed
absolutely that's where we want to take
you to and so we're we're going to put
you on the we're going to put you on the
every dollar budget it's an app that we
have the world's best budgeting app I'm
going to give it to you free I'm going
to put you in our class it's called
Financial Peace University I'm going to
give that to you for free because I've
been 25 and scared I remember how it
feels and I I and I used to have uh
money running through my fingers too I
know exactly how that out of control
feels and you wake up with a financial
hangover which is worse than a real one
and um so yeah that I don't want you
having that anymore I want this to get
this out of your life so here's the deal
we're going to put you into all of that
if and and I want you to start
immediately paying down cutting up the
credit card get debit cards don't spend
money you don't have and and begin to
tear through these first two debts the
credit cards and the student loan what's
your student loan
payment um it's about 170 a month yeah
is that as low as you can get it for now
I can get it I mean I can definitely try
and give them a call and see if I can
decrease that but it's a it's a
temporary thing because really what we
want is $4,000 make the whole thing go
away MH yeah all right and so here's the
deal let's if you add $4,000 this
equation credit cards are gone in one
month four more months the student loans
are
gone yeah right you do the math with me
there yes that's pretty amazing that's
why so Jade's Jade's telling you the
secret sauce baby it's you okay and then
we're going to tear into this and if you
are not up back up to $100,000 a year in
your current job by March you do need to
sell this car it's too expensive if
you're making a 100 you can keep it but
you got to pay it off sou you should be
100% debt free in your world in a year
from today if you'll follow the stuff we
teach and that involves selling the car
if you don't get your income up but if
you do get your income up you'll be able
to pay it off and still keep it all
within a year hang on we'll get you
signed up for every
[Music]
dollar
Jade washaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host today Angela is in Washington DC
Angela welcome to the Ramsey
Show hi Dave and hi Jade how are you
doing today doing better than we deserve
what's
up so I am a 37 year old single female
um and I have found myself in a little
bit of um well a whole lot of debt um I
have two whole life insurance policies
um that I would like to cash out or
Surrender the policies they total about
$1,000 um my question is the cash value
is 11 or the
face the cash value is 11,000 what's the
face what's it pay if you die the face
um the face value for both of these
policies um is about2 ,000 okay all
right and you're paying monthly on
them yes okay all right go
ahead um and about four years ago I was
diagnosed with cancer and at this
current point in time I'm uninsurable so
I was thinking about cashing them
surrendering the policies for
$11,000 so I can start baby step two and
you know create an aggressive plan the
snowball method to pay off my debt
should I keep these policies considering
of of my illness or um should I
Surrender them and start my death my
debt
repayment what's your
income um I make about
$140,000 a year this includes a 20y year
,000 from a rental property how much
debt out my basement how much debt do
you have um right now I'm probably at
about 240,000 what kind of debt um 128
student loans about $45,000 in credit
card debt I have about $330,000 left on
a home renovation loan and I have a
$30,000 car loan
okay and what's
your uh with the cancer how you doing
how are you
doing I'm doing good I'm doing good now
um some of this debt is contributed to
that just kind of you know paying
medical bills um I was
I'm not a medical expert but are you in
remission are you okay or are you still
in the middle of fighting it and you're
doing good or what's going on no I'm
doing I'm doing good you're on just
maintenance I'm in complete remission
and I'm on maintenance therapy okay
great great uh what kind of cancer did
you have just it was breast cancer okay
all right and so it is in the rearview
mirror right now how long have have you
been uh cancer
free um since about 20
21 okay two years okay all right all
right I'm thinking more like an
insurance person than a uh medical
person right now that's what I'm trying
to do because I I don't I mean I know
very little about this except just
having been around it as a human being
but I'm not a medical person you follow
me so um but the experience that
um I've had I mean I have uh two or
three L ladies almost within eyesight of
me right now that on our team that have
been through that and are a couple of
years the other side of it and are doing
fine um and the prognosis is excellent
for them um but you're right they're not
they're not insurable for life insurance
today uh but in terms of their life
their life looks really good you follow
me yes and that's I'm just judging it
based on that I'm not again it's not a
medical diagnosis I don't know anything
about that but I do know you can't get
life insurance I do agree with that
today so uh you're single do you have
any children
no not so you have no
dependence okay that affects this
because I'm very hesitant to have
someone who's uninsurable cancel
Insurance cuz you can't get it right now
and if you even have a scare let's say
you go three or four years and then you
have a scare you're not going to get it
for another three or four years so you
might end up going a decade I I if with
no hiccups maybe three or four more
years you'll be getting it right but um
but if you had a minor uh hiccup it
could be a decade without it and your
life could change a lot at 37 in one
decade you follow me all right so I'm
always hesitant to lose something that
you can never get back and that's this
insurance you can't get it back anytime
soon um the good news is I also go ahead
I also have a term um oh great policy
it's it's term 80 it has a face value a
death benefit right now of
$150,000
okay that's extra information that's
very helpful thank you yes cancel your
whole life cancel your whole life I have
a long-term long-term disability policy
and a long-term care policy and I had
all of these policies before I was
diagnosed diagnosed good okay okay yes I
would cancel your whole life if I were
you okay because you here's the thing no
one is counting on your income if you
were to pass away so $150,000 cleans
up takes care of your funeral and cleans
up the vast majority of your debts and
the sale of your house cleans up the
rest of
them agreed right so your mom dad
brother sister somebody cleans up your
estate and you've got the money to do
every bit of that and um there's no
burden left to anyone there's no one
that was left counting on your income
and that doesn't have it like a Child
Left Behind that kind of a thing which
is the primary use of life insurance is
to make sure the family's okay so given
all of that and that you have this 150
inter in place um
and uh 3 years from now you get married
and have kids and you get some life
insurance to just you know to cover a
family situation and you've had then
five or six years in remission you're
become insurable uh most likely at that
point then yeah then you've got a fine
plan you see what I'm
doing yes and that's that I'm just
trying to kind of anticipate but the
$11,000 doesn't fix your debt mess you
got to go fix that with your $140,000
income right and you got you got to
start really cleaning that up uh and you
have to get very very serious about
living on beans and rice rice and beans
but getting rid of the stinking payment
cuz this whole life payment is what 500
bucks 400
bucks all of my life insurance policies
premiums um I pay $58 a month for
everything yeah but how much of that's
the term
90 uh the the term insurance is $88 a
year um my whole life is about
$2,000 a year yeah so we're saving
$2,000 a year that's what I'm more
concerned about then the 8,000 MH okay
and so or the $1,000 the $111,000 yeah
you can pay off some of the debt um
start cleaning up uh you know the car
the renov whether you keep the car or
not I don't know all that but yeah the
answer to your question is yes I would
you drop you got a whole picture here
we're looking at that tell you to drop
this but the number of times in 30 years
on the air I have told someone who's
uninsurable to drop a life insurance
policy even as much as I hate whole life
is very very low almost never well yeah
cuz what are you going to replace it
with nothing you're you're you're in a
mess and I almost never would tell you
do that I hate whole life life insurance
it's a piece of crap of a product but in
your case we're saving you 2,000 bucks a
year plus put $111,000 in your pocket
for something that you don't even really
need yeah yeah in her case no and uh so
the uninsurable just adds drama to the
question well luckily she had the term
policy in place if she didn't everything
if she didn't she had two whole lives
worth 200,000 would you have advis her
to keep both of them or let go of one I
might have let go of one I I would have
parched them out and figured out which
was which and that I'm afraid the term
insurance is probably expensive that's
why I guessed I guessed accurately on
the price because she bought it from a
whole life company when you buy term
from a whole life company they Jack the
term price up to try to show you that
there's not much difference between the
two and you end up paying more than if
you went to Xander insurance and shopped
among a bazillion companies and got the
best possible deal uh so you know if you
go to a whole life company and buy term
insurance expect to pay 25 to 50% more
so for nothing for nothing absolutely
nothing except the their marketing plan
so um but that the whole the whole
industry is just Wicked the term
insurance is the only way to go 15 to 20
year level term about 10 to 12 times
your income go to Xander insurance.com
they'll shop about a a handful of
different companies of bazillion
companies get you the best possible deal
and um you know you're going to be in
great shape then and you're going to
kick everybody's butt in the marketplace
if you're insurable she doesn't have
that option mhm yeah so good question
thank you for calling in and I'm glad
you're doing okay me too this is the
Ramsey
[Music]
Show
[Applause]
[Music]
Jade washaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host today so when I started teaching
this
information 35 years
ago I had discovered common
sense
God's and Grandma's ways of handling
money after I went
broke when I went broke I was making
aund couple hundred, a year and I had a
net worth of a million dollars in real
estate and I have all the letters and
licenses after my name and all the
academic bull crap that says I'm
supposed to know something about money
and I went broke so obviously something
I learned with the academic bull crap
was just that bull crap now obviously
some of it was right but I learned Leed
from old people that had money and from
basic Common Sense things in the Bible
that you have to live on less than you
make you have to live on a budget a
written plan no one goes to success
accidentally you have
to get out of debt and stay out of debt
your most powerful wealth building tool
is your income you have to save and
invest and discover the eighth wonder of
the world Einstein called it compound
interest and you have to be outrageously
generous these are five components that
are principles of life that are ancient
and they are
proven then the next thing I had to
figure out and it's took me a few years
was in how do I apply them in the real
world well I'm going to cut up my credit
cards I'm going to get on a budget I'm
going to not borrow money for car what
do I do if I'm in debt well we're going
to use the debt snowball and get out of
debt oh I've got to have an emergency
fund do I do that before a retirement
plan oh I've got to save for my kids
college oh wait we need to pay off the
house oh my goodness where do we start
which of these comes first I don't know
what to do so we took the five
principles and I put them into a process
a proven plan a path that we nicknamed
the baby steps now the baby steps are
not ancient well they're 30 years old
but they're not ancient like ancient wi
wisdom from Proverbs okay but the
principles that I talked about the five
things are all woven into the baby steps
and it gives you an order of attack and
we've taught people that the first thing
you do save $1,000 a little starter
emergency fund it's not enough but it's
just for now the second thing you do
baby step two is you pay off all your
debts except your house with great
focused intensity you live on nothing
and you list your debts smallest to
largest and attack them in that order
then when you're out of debt everything
but the house boom you're in the top 10%
of Americans right then and then we're
going to go ahead and finish the
emergency fund at 3 to 6 months of
expenses then we can let off the gas and
let the intensity go down and let it
change to intentionality and we
simultaneously do baby steps four five
and six save for 15% for retirement save
for kids college and start paying off
the house a six when the house is paid
off it takes you to baby step seven
which is everything is paid off now
there's nothing left to do but build
wealth and become uh very very generous
so in the midst of that Jade we've
taught this and you've you've taught it
as well you're running into some
detailed questions about four five and
six the return at the college and the
house yeah the people on social media
are like you're always talking about
paying off the debt Jade what about for
us who have gotten through it can we
have a deep dive on baby steps four five
and six and I'm like yes so I went
through I look at my DM on Instagram and
I do look at some of the questions on
Facebook and I try to pull 10 that I
feel like are the most asked questions
so let's frequently ask questions on
Jade's DM yes let's clip through these
so the first better Dave reads me in
tweets yeah well let me add one to it
just because you mentioned it so on baby
step four Dave is it my pre-tax number
that I'm doing the 15% or is it my after
tax number my take PRX pre tax your
gross revenue so if you make $100,000 a
year you need to say 15,000 if you make
200,000 you need to save 30,000 there
you go well Dave if I'm on baby step 4
and all of a sudden I use up my
emergency fund do I have to stop baby
step four which is investing the 15% in
order to restock my emergency fund if
you can't restock it within two months
yes within two months so there's your
you you don't want to be going without
an emergency fund when you walk around
without an emergency fund it attracts
bad luck MH it's like Murphy is looking
at got me one oh yeah you know so two
months is the rle on that how about this
one how do I toggle between baby step 3B
which is saving for a down payment on a
house and baby step 4 do I pick one or
the other when do I focus on one over
the other you take that one all right so
I would say that if you're going to
spend more than two years saving up baby
step 3B I might consider adding baby
step 4 to it and if you're going to a if
you're able to save up that down payment
really quickly then I would just stop
baby step 4 when you're done go on to
baby step four yeah like 6 months pour
the heat on no retir yeah and then go
back to then go to retirement full on
okay and sometimes people do I'll take
the match my employer matches six so
I'll do 6% inste of 15 while I'm doing
3B yeah you can yeah you can do them at
the same time but ultimately we don't
want you to uh want do no retirement for
more than two or three years that's
right that's right let's see number
three what do I do uh if I make too much
day four Roth IRA back door Roth aha
back door Roth is you open an after tax
ra traditional and roll it to a Roth
instantaneously I do it every year and I
do it for my wife as well every year we
we have fully funded roths every single
year um perfectly legal it's a loophole
in the tax law that's right and by the
way when you say you open what you
really mean is work with a I work with
my smart Vestor Pro they do it I don't
do it there you go I just want to
clarify that because on the Instagrams
they're saying you do it like you do
your own the only thing I do on my
investing is um I throw money in an S&P
500 park it till I get my next real
estate deal that's oh that's baby step
seven stuff there yeah so let me jump
down to question 10 because it goes
along with it it says do I really need
to use a financial adviser to choose the
funds in my 401k or can I just pick the
funds myself you can pick them yourself
in a
401k um but you need a good financial
adviser in your corner not to tell you
what to do but to teach you that's right
and then the other thing if you're
watching the news and you go oh God
Israel's at War the stock market's going
to dive we're all going to die you know
you need somebody talk you off the ledge
and keep you invested cuz you don't want
to jump off in the middle of the roller
coaster ride I know that's right all
right what to do with extra money when
your home is paid off my home is paid
off I have maxed my 401k my IRA and my
HSA is also maxed what else can I
do uh well there's two things that
people do I only do one well three
things I only do as far as investing
what can other people I buy real estate
that I pay cash for MH and as it goes up
in value you do not pay taxes on the
increase in value until you sell it well
Dave I'm not really into real estate I
don't want to be a landlord buy a low
turnover mutual fund and that means they
don't sell the stock inside of it very
often so it doesn't have taxes you only
pay taxes when you sell out of the
mutual fund on 98% of it you know if you
got a low turnover ratio mutual fund um
and so like an S&P 500 generally would
be that
and that's why I use those to park extra
money in what about these reats they're
fine uh just check your track record on
that's a real estate investment trust
it's basically a mutual fund for Real
Estate uh in the old days they stacked
them with fees so high that the returns
were much less than grow stock mutual
funds but in the last 10 years or so
they've really come on they've doing a
much better job of running them and um I
don't buy those because I buy real
estate right but they're not bad and
just check the track record on them love
that what amount extra should I put onto
the mortgage or should you ever stop the
mortgage to increase investing or vice
versa 15% of your household income into
retirement at baby step four something
into kids college at baby step five and
any other money we find above
lifestyle we put on the mortgage until
the mortgage is gone the two key areas
of people that get their first $1 to5
million of net worth and all the
research and data that we have says a
beefy 401K Roth IR a retirement plan and
a paid off house love that those are the
two places to go to get rich for college
saving Esa or
529 uh they they're the same thing the
esa the good news about it is there's
only one kind and you control it the 529
there's three different kinds and only
one of them is good and the one that you
control is the one that's good true but
don't get into pre 529 is Prepaid
College you don't do Prepaid College you
don't do that that's a bad 529 and
with your smart vest Pro is the same
thing as an Esa you select the mutual
funds and you're just fine cool good job
Dave quick rapid
[Music]
fire
our scripture today proverbs 14:15 the
simple believe anything but the prudent
give thought to their
steps George Bernard Shaw said 2% of
people are thinking 3% of people think
they are thinking 95% of humans would
rather die than think oh
gosh hardcore George hardcore buddy
probably right Amy's in Charlotte North
Carolina hey Amy welcome to the Ramsey
show thank you for taking my call
sure what's up I have a question so I
just um I'm about to close on a house
it's a
$330,000 house that I put 18% down so I
put $60,000 on down and so the house
comes in bare doesn't have refrigerator
nothing at all and of course those are
the things that I have to buy and I'm
just wondering um like how should I go
about it without getting into
debt
did you know I'm just I have to ask
going into buying this house did you
know that there wasn't going to be any
appliances Inside Yes I I did know so
what's your
plan you know what so I I have um so I I
put aside so I I still have like
20,000 um kind of like kind of you know
kind of my sa my saved up um to just um
just get things at really bare minimum
and I have lived 35 years without having
to ever buy Furnitures so everything is
going to be brand like if I have to get
everything from beds to fridge to washer
and dryer yeah that 20,000 was that your
emergency fund
correct yeah I don't I don't want you to
use your emergency fund for something
that's not an
emergency so let's just play pretend a
minute you close on a $330,000 house you
spend your last $20,000 Furnishing it
the next day
something's going to go wrong and you
have no
money right that's why Jay doesn't want
you to spend your emergency
fund so how how should I do about them
how should I go about I mean that was
your plan to move into the house
broke
yeah so that Dave said it that was your
plan to move into the house you're going
to have to move very slowly and very
methodically what do you make I make um
I make uh 35 taxfree and make around
like 40 has to be
taxed so I make um 75 70 yeah how do
where do you get taxfree
income um from um retirement from the
military like disabilities okay so
what's your what do you bring home each
month help me out five 5,000
okay so let's see here and you're
completely debt free or did you buy this
house with no $330,000 mortgage no no no
I meant other debt oh you have other
debt so I have no other debt and I
finance house
275,000 oh you put 60 down on 330
purchase okay that's better okay so what
this looks like is every month you're
going to be doing a detailed budget in
order to figure out how much margin do
you have to put towards what the most
important thing is so if I'm you I'm
making a priorities
list the the place you live now do you
have furniture in it
no I I'm I'm renting a room so
everything is furnished and I'm not sure
if that relevant but my boyfriend's
going to be moving in and my other
question is it's going to be my house
and he's going to help me pay for
mortgage and I'm trying to pay it be
like kind of within like 20 years and
he's going to help me half of the more
get but since he's in my house and I
wonder what is the fair amount that he
should pay in because I you know at the
end of the day if we don't work out it's
going to be my house and I don't want to
screw somebody over and what do you guys
think is fair so you my um yeah okay so
let me back up to the other part first
okay um you're renting a room and you
don't own a bed no I don't own anything
at all okay all right um the first thing
I want you to do is I want you to take
$5,000 and go buy a mattress and a bed
and I want you to buy a used
refrigerator and I want you to use the
laundry mat until you can save up the
money and buy washing drive that's going
to leave you 15,000 in your emergency
fund and then you're going to cash flow
Furnishing this place out of your income
so every month or two you're going to
buy another Appliance another piece of
furniture and you're going to pay cash
as you go the you don't do this with a
mattress but everything else in the
house go to the rich end of town and go
to the garage sale and you can buy a
$99,000 leather couch for 500 bucks at a
garage sale in the rich end of town cuz
the lady redecorated and didn't like the
color anymore okay and that's how you're
going to furnish this place the first
round of furniture um get a decent
refrigerator that's kind of gets life
started you can go to the laundry mat
until Christmas and then you can save up
and buy a washer and dryer if you want
to do it faster you can buy used washer
and dryer and later on upgrade to a new
one all with cash and sell your used one
on Craigslist okay so you're going
15,000 you have to keep in the account
$5,000 budget to get you started with a
bed and a refrigerator and a couple of
other items okay okay does that make
sense to you that way if you you have an
emergency you don't lose your
home yeah that would be so you know I
feel like yeah you know I I got a
beautiful house and my
myal you took it all you took it all the
way to the edge kiddo I mean you left no
margin in this deal I mean you can't you
can't breathe the way you've got this
tightened up so tight then the second
piece is um I don't recommend that you
ever buy a house or depend on someone
that you're not married to to pay for
your house and so if you're going to
choose to shack up with him um I would
PR my preference as an old guy who has a
couple of daughters and I know how
sometimes people get treated in these
situations is I would say he can't move
in unless he got married cuz there's
kind of that thing you know and it's
much better for you you're the one that
comes out on the short end of the stick
not the
guy Oh I thought it was the other way
around no you're the one that comes out
that does not go well for the ladies in
these situations economically the
economics really suck for the ladies in
these things so um and somehow guys keep
talking them into it but I'm not sure
how um so I you know I'll just be old
fogy and you can be mad at if you want
to I love you and I want you to win and
I'm telling you the truth of what I
would do if I were in your shoes or what
I do tell my little sister or my best
friend or whatever he doesn't move in
unless he gets married um you run your
own life and if he's a man and wants to
step up and serve his uh spouse then
yeah he can come on board here and we'll
go aside from that if you're going to do
this don't depend on him to do it and
then you can just decide there's not a
fair price for shacking up
there's not a shacking up schedule MH we
don't have a schedule for that uh
there's not a price on it so um you just
got to decide you know who's paying for
the mustard who's paying for the
mayonnaise who's paying for the bread
who's paying for the lights who's paying
for the water or what percentage or
whatever and you got a roommate room you
know it's a roommate situation and it's
just like in college that's my mustard
you know I mean it's the same stuff and
so uh that's the problem you get into
and it doesn't Bo B well statistically
the data points don't bode well for your
future wealth building in this scenario
and it doesn't bode well for his future
wealth building there's actually what we
call a marital advantage in the
statistics out there in the data people
who are married have an economic
advantage over those who are not the
data is slam dunk it's not even close so
something to consider I got all up in
your business but you asked darling so
um but yeah as far as the house go goes
15,000 in the account get a refrigerator
and a bed use furniture on the rest of
it work your way up with cash flow what
do you think I yeah I I was shocked you
gave her the 5,000 out of the 20 if I'm
being honest but well I think she's
going to go buy a refrigerator I don't
think we can stop her look Jade warshaw
would have said you better get you a air
mattress and stop
playing I'm not telling her to get a
real mattress you getting an air
mattress and you get you a college
refrigerator I'm talking about the
little guy that goes on the floor
because I want this as a reminder
to never do dumb stuff like that again
yeah never take never take yourself all
the way the edge that's the dumb thing
you took yourself all the way the edge
and then what should have been a
blessing can end up being a curse and
that's what we're afraid for honey
living like a rapper in this in this big
old house and no furniture with no
furniture that's how rappers live I
didn't know that giant gold chain I
didn't know that okay and no money just
learned some that puts us hour the
Ramsey Show in the books we'll be back
with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the Prince of
Peace Christ Jesus hey what's up guys
it's Jade look if you like what you
heard in this episode and want to know
more about getting started on the ramsy
baby steps go to ramseys solutions.com
and click the get started button we'll
help you figure out the best next step
for you based on your specific situation
that's ramseys solutions.com and click
get
[Music]
started